so in this section I'm going to describe
about string compression and
burrows-wheeler transform in the
previous section Philip we have a great
description of the suffix tree it allows
us to find a pattern very quickly but at
this and at the same time the memory and
learn and the runtime requires for
constructing the suffix tree for the
genome is linear big all of the size of
the genome but if some of you believe
Philip and trying to construct a suffix
tree for mammalian genomes on your
desktop or laptop you will have problem
with memory why because the Big O
notation C ignores an important constant
the best no suffix tree implementation
requires about 20 times the length of
the genome can we reduce this constant
factor into one or even smaller I now
switch the topic I want to talk about
genome compression it seems to tell you
that shown just changed the topic very
quickly but I will promise that the
thing that I'm going to describe that is
how to compress a genome will have a
relation to the problem that we are
discussing today that is multiple
pattern matching but allow me to
describe the genome compression first we
knew this string is there a way to
present it shorter or is there a way to
compress it well you can see that you
have a lot of brands of G and C and a
and T and so on so instead of writing
the genome in this form you can write
10g instead of writing 10g you have just
write 10 and G instead of writing C 11
times you can just write 11
so you see that if the genome has a lot
of brands like this it would be easy to
compress but the problem is that the
genomes they don't have lot of of read
but they do have lots of ribbet
can we somehow transform the genome with
lots of ribbet into another string
genome star with a lot of breaths and
then run the run length encoding
algorithm to compress the genome how we
do with this step let me describe the
Bureau we love transform let's have a
string banana bananas terminated with a
special character dollar sign
let's first form all cyclic rotations of
panama banana we start with me the next
one is dollar sign next one I start with
s and so on so forth we start an
exposition so there n possible rotations
right yes what should we do next
now I sorted all the strings in
lexicographic order you see the color
here just to show you that these strings
are sorted what is the burrows-wheeler
transform of these sticks if you check
the last column of this text it is
called the BWT
but why would we care about the last
column well let's look at an example
this is actually the text form Crick and
Watson for the double helix structure of
the DNA and this is the one region of
the BWT
so you see the last column is BWT it has
a lot of runs
why because the tax here has a lot of
repetitive words in this case it is the
word end a nd you may ask me another
question
why don't I choose the first column as
the BWT
well it also contains a lot of runs
right yes what I believe Phillip will
give you a better explanation